this holiday was weird for me I'll tell
you why it was okay tell me why it's
weird because I did nothing isn't that
good and that was the weirdest thing
I've experienced all year I think that's
how you know we're fogging overworked
ourselves it's just it's just like oh
what I'm sitting here and it's like what
do I do with my hands it was so weird
right because uh we're coming back from
Christmas and New Year's I remember it
was like the
27th or something or 20th 28th of like
December yeah and I was I remember like
I remember thinking God we've been like
we're not film trash taste but I feel
like three weeks it was seven days and I
was just like holy [ __ ] I feel like I've
been off work for a month now what the
hell man oh my God yeah I mean like I
for one experienced probably the worst
Christmas and New Year's of my goddamn
life
uh because I I mean I mentioned it very
briefly but I had a gastroenteritis or
stomach flu and it was probably using
like the cursive version
what do you mean it's your stomach flu
why are you doing
because it's more serious yeah because
gastroenteritis sounds way cool I was
gonna say when you because you did an
Instagram post I was like the [ __ ] is
that yeah I Googled it I was like what
this what is [ __ ] stomach flu well
because I didn't because that's I've
always known it as that term I never
knew it was called stomach flu yeah so
people will like
do you mean some people like do you mean
stomach flu I'm like oh that makes more
sense this is literally just the Winnie
the Pooh meme with uh yeah
yeah so uh I had the stomach flu
um which for those of you don't know is
like kind of like a worser version of
food poisoning That's the only way to
just lose that right yeah unlike food
poisoning an actual illness
um but yeah how do you get it uh so I
mean there's a lot of ways you can get
it um for one like the most common way
is kind of like food poisoning where you
like you just eat something bad or you
drink something that was kind of off
with hands
yeah it's like food poisoning except if
it was like built like Mayweather you
know it's like it's it's like this thing
like punches the crap out you can die
from food poisoning right can you die
from stomach flu or is it kind of
different it's more of a I think I don't
think you can die from stomach flu but
you can develop other illnesses so like
a lot of people who have like stomach
ulcers for example and stuff like that
get it as a result of like really bad
stomach flu yeah um so basically I got
that and I was basically bedridden for
about eight days
um and I've had and I've had stomach flu
before like I've I've gotten it in like
Australia and like the US and stuff like
that but never in Japan and like
normally even like in the worst like
kind of like food poisoning right the
worst is like maybe a couple of days and
then you get it out of your system and
you're good but like this I don't man
this this boy wanted to hang around for
the holidays he was just like oh you're
alone at home Arc is overseas I'll be
your company this holiday season this
either you're just home alone just dying
I was just dying like Christmas Eve for
example is probably like the peak and it
just felt like [ __ ] I was just getting
stabbed in the stomach and I was going
to the toilet every like five minutes
just like vomiting or just like hissing
through my ass and it was I was
absolutely horrible
um yeah and so it got really bad around
day five and
yeah day five it got really bad in day
five so bad to the point where I was
like I don't know if this is like a
stomach flu anymore I feel like this is
something worse so I went to the
hospital yeah
um imagine [ __ ] Christmas Eve I'm I'm
at the [ __ ] hospital because my
stomach is dying you where like an old
man would approach you in the street and
give you something to make you believe
that Christmas is real on your way to
the hospital yeah free trip to the
hospital he's like oh I've given you a
rice cake Christmas uh Christmas cheer
does exist yeah congratulations thank
you so much he said instead of an old
man it was a it was an old man in a
doctor's outfit yeah you're telling me
that yeah I just had a really bad case
of the stomach flu he gave me some
medicine to be like yeah you'll probably
be fine in a couple of days
um and then yeah I finally got better
around the first or the second of
January so how do you get stomach flu is
it from eating something dodgy yeah
okay so there's a couple of speculations
yeah so obviously obviously I had a lot
of time yeah to look this up
ain't doing anything else yeah I'm just
lying in bed for eight days I'm like
well I guess I'll learn something new in
the medicine field too yeah
um so I looked it up um like the most
common way is like again kind of like
food poisoning where it's like you
either eat something that was maybe like
a little undercooked or a little bit you
know rotten or you know you drink
something where your stomach just like
doesn't take it and stuff like that yeah
another way you can get it is it's
called a stomach fluid because it's
actually like
um you can get it from someone else oh
oh so someone with like a a stomach flu
say coughs for example yeah and you're
in the vicinity there is a chance you
can catch it that way as well oh Jesus
um so I think though what happened was
that like I know exactly the day it
happened because two days before uh I
went out drinking with a couple of my
friends
um Manu uh yeah uh Ohara good friend of
ours um Marky maylene's husband and then
my other Japanese friend we went out
drinking and I know it was that day
because when I told the boys I was like
yo I got the stomach flu and it might
have been on this day all three of them
are like yeah we're kind of sick as well
oh God so it was definitely that day it
was either something we ate or something
we drank but it's weird because we
didn't eat anything raw that day maybe
you just think that wasn't enough it
must have been something that was like
maybe undercooked or wasn't stored
properly it does happen a lot more in
Japan than you think as I am a testament
to this it does happen a lot anything
but what's so weird is that like I've
never had any kind of like food
poisoning or anything like that in Japan
let alone something that bad like again
it's like I've had it before but it
lasted maybe like a day or two at most
but this guy was just Clinging On to
dear life and he was just like I'm gonna
make your holidays absolutely miserable
this year so I definitely uh I got a PB
of the worst Christmas that's for sure
um you know I thought it was bad enough
that I was shoveling [ __ ] in the snow uh
one year is even a blizzard no that's
nothing compared to this this was
definitely by far the worst I mean I can
laugh about it now but yeah man it was
horrible at least like my Saving Grace
was that it didn't happen during a week
where I had a lot of stuff like we
didn't have anything
so sad isn't it didn't you say that the
symptoms started to come on on the 23rd
yeah literally which is the day after
the last crash taste recording so
luckily like the only thing I had
planned was that you know because it was
the last week of December right yeah so
I was like oh okay we've got no trash
taste we've I have no filming you know
scheduled or anything like that yes so
so I filled up that entire week with
like you know seeing friends or like you
know I was supposed to go up to Sendai
to like see my grandma over the new
years I had to cancel all of that
um and just wither away alone in bed on
during the last week of 2022 so my year
ended uh great so I hope uh you guys and
everyone watching had a better holiday
than I did but how polite of the illness
to wait for the day after you film is
you know he was he was he was like you
know what you know what the boys need it
the boys need it okay let him go for
that yeah I don't know I remember like I
was saying I was telling this to God
earlier today and in my head I was just
like man that is the most Japanese
salary man thing I've ever said in my
life it's like well at least I didn't
miss out on work you know because
everyone knows that's the most important
baby I feel like I have my holidays I
willed my body into not being sick like
twice like recently oh really felt like
I was gonna be sick and I was like no
really wow how so do you know you wake
up with the throat it's a little bit
like oh no oh no I actually had the same
holiday and I feel like I [ __ ] willed
it I was like yeah [ __ ] dare dude
[ __ ] I just got back from my hall and I
was like I need to work I want to work
but I remember I was just like no I'm
not I'm not even giving this attention
I'm not even gonna I'm not a bit pretend
like this isn't happening yeah and then
literally next day I was fine yeah sick
the day after I was like oh God it's
coming back and like no no it's like it
comes back when you least expect it it's
like you forgot about me baby I'll take
a little throat thing I'll I'll chill
out I'll drink a ton of water um I'm
gonna ignore this I'm just gonna do it
yeah I'm fine oh actually yeah I don't
know if this is I say I don't know this
it's 100 [ __ ] that I've just made up
in my head to tell myself that I'm I'm
strong enough to [ __ ] this thing over
see but it's weird right because like
there's I remember there's like and
again I don't know how true these are
but like I've heard you know on and off
about like yeah that whole thing of like
you know if you think hard enough that
like oh that's all [ __ ] the disease
goes away then it actually goes away you
know
[Music]
exactly the same thing happened to me uh
this holiday where like early on like
Joey I had um I woke up and I just had
like this sore throat that just would
not go away right I didn't say anything
about it yeah
um and then I go upstairs and Sydney
comes down and she's like oh I think I
got a sore throat and I'm like [ __ ]
don't don't say that because if you have
something red that just means I'm I'm
not just like imagining this pain in my
throat right right right so we're just
like I told Sydney no we're not gonna
let this ruin our [ __ ] holiday or
right it's it's like it's not real it's
not real you literally you literally
just pulled out no you don't it's
Christmas Eve that's crazy
so she believes that she doesn't have it
and it moves quickly
it was [ __ ] Christmas Eve right and
I'm like we're gonna open a bottle of
wine
we're gonna watch some [ __ ] horror
movies and uh we're gonna we're gonna
drink the pain away right it's all right
the alcohol will kill the disease this
is the worst medical advice in history
we are not MediCal experts do not listen
to any of this no yes this is like the
same level of logic as like you know
when you're one step away from getting
hypothermic you're like just take a shot
I don't know if I and this is probably
[ __ ] right I feel like there is
something in my head right when I resign
especially if common colds and stuff
like this when I resign that in my head
that I'm like I'm sick that's when I
become more sick yeah in my head when I
tell myself I'm not sick this is a joke
and I just keep powering on I don't I
feel like I get less sick I don't know
if this is complete [ __ ] I feel like
it is I don't know why this happens
scientists explained why I feel this no
Okay Okay no Okay I totally get that
though because I mean with the stomach
flu that I had when I was starting to
like actually you know physically feel
that I was like oh here it comes in my
head I was like no I don't I don't I
don't want this I don't
I started to get like stummy cramps and
I decided to get like a bit of a fever
and I was like no no it's fine it's
probably just like built up stress or
something no not right now not right now
but then the stomach flu is like what's
your Source
it's like oh really you don't have an
illness do you may I see your receipts
please go hands man all right I got me
this because like it's like I'm about to
cancel your entire holidays
what do you think okay do you think the
body is capable of doing things that
science can't really explain sometimes
because we hear we hear some kind of
these like stories every now and then or
like people who can do incredible things
it just feels like one of those alpha
male conversations yeah these guys in
the jungle in uh in Malaysia they are
they actually found a fruit that allows
you to grow your dick how do you become
so Alpha that you can control your body
to the face
how do you unlock 100 of yourselves I
think there's like like a law of
attraction where if you get three dudes
on a podcast eventually they'll talk
about the human body
I feel like this is just
a natural phenomenon that happens and it
is so [ __ ] dumb because we're all
[ __ ] stupid can we coin this is The
Joe Rogan no no I don't give him credit
I
names because they come up with dumb
[ __ ] like the the skips they're like the
cheetoskip
that's my favorite thing with like the
speed running like things it's like it's
like when when speedrun has come up with
like names of Tricks there's one or two
ways that you can name it the one way is
like to be like you name it after what
you're doing it so it's like this one is
called the boulder skip because you use
a boulder to skip it and then the other
way is like this one is called the gym
sandwich because Jim was eating a
sandwich when he discovered it there's
only two ways you can name